okay so as we've all heard or if you
haven't heard you're about to hear 2011
officially marks the release of scream 4
or screw form as the poster calls it and
if anyone remembers that for scream 3
came out Wes Craven said scream is a
trilogy and the trilogy is done there is
no more scream there will not be a
scream 4 yeah we all knew that was
[ __ ]
the first scream like the original
scream and it first came out I thought
it was really enjoyable because it
openly addressed a lot of the cliches
that horror movies and movies in general
always fall into and screams always had
the rules I've always liked the rules
I'm sure screw form we'll have a list of
rules that one must abide by in order to
successfully reboot a franchise but I'll
do it for you right here because I'm all
hurt like that like that guy because
there are certain rules that will must
abide by in order to successfully
rebooted franchise with a force equal
number one it must feel forced the third
movie filled in all the gaps and showed
us that what we believe to be true
wasn't actually true and the story arc
came full circle by revealing and taking
out the person who actually started
everything in the first movie to begin
with the only thing to do now is to
either leave it alone no such luck or
force an ill-conceived story arc in the
form of Sidney Prescott's evil twin or
multiple personality disorder number two
do not expect to see anything you have
not seen before this is the fourth
installment of a slasher flick you will
not see any new content here if for
nothing else this will be a best-of
compilation that happened to get a
theatrical release and number three
never ever under any circumstances ever
actually assume if the characters you
liked in the previous films actually
matter this time because they won't
matter for a couple reasons one because
they're gonna be replaced by younger
hipper hotter people and two the
resolution that they reached at the end
of the third movie will be totally
negated by the simple creation of the
fourth movie and if their issues and
resolution don't matter then they don't
matter I think that makes sense and yes
I do know that Neve Campbell David
Arquette and Courtney Cox actually did
sign on for script form but that doesn't
mean they're gonna matter now Wes Craven
did address at the pattern of horror
movies is that they make a zillion
sequels and then remakes and reboots and
he did say that screw form is gonna poke
fun at this so who knows maybe scream 4
will be a fun slap in the face to studio
douches and reboots and remakes but for
the time being I'm gonna go ahead and
stick to my rules I listed earlier but
what's the catchphrase tsk reform new
decade new rules so we get a new rule
now we get like four rules instead of
three all right here we go
rule number four it'll probably be
released in 3d I wouldn't be surprised
so what do you guys think of scream 4
yay nay cool [ __ ] comment below let
the world know
[Music]